for peak performance your body tries to  stay at 37 degrees during exercise it  does this by sweating losing up to a  liter of fluid per hour when you workout  this liquid needs replacing  or you'll dehydrate your temperature and  heart rate will go up and you'll feel  tired sooner just drinking water isn't  always enough because when you sweat you  don't just lose water you lose  electrolytes too  sodium is the key electrolyte for fluid  balance and hydration if you only drink  water you can dilute the sodium levels  in your blood you'll need more toilet  breaks and performance is affected  hydrating with SAS keeps these fluid and  sodium levels topped up keeping you on  top of your game try SAS go hydro and go  electrolyte for hydration